they're pissed off that they're taking a
statue down because they're [ __ ]
traitors they don't want the
constitution they don't want democracy
they don't want that they don't want
equal rights they don't want equity they
don't want it they don't want it it's
their white grievance that's the whole
point
and we're gonna see some more
white male fragility today a [ __ ] ton of
it here
but that's what this is
white male fragility grievance
and robert e lee was a [ __ ] traitor
and the only [ __ ] hero that he is to
is two [ __ ] traitors
to this country
the land of the free the land of the
brave you know
star spangled banner and [ __ ]
give me a [ __ ] break you
you goddamn spread neck fake patriots
you're not even you're
pluck your head out of your [ __ ]
asses and realize
that
robert e lee
tried to overthrow the government of the
united states and what's funny about
that
what's funny about the the original
confederacy trying to overthrow the
government of the united states because
they wanted to own other human beings
they wanted to own other human beings as
property that's why they were trying to
you know
bang up the united states because united
states basically said you can't own
other human beings anymore
so they were they were treasonous
against the united states because the
united states wouldn't let them own
human beings
that's why there was a war you [ __ ]
idiots
the craziest part about it all
is robert e lee didn't go to washington
and throw a rally
and encourage people to go overthrow the
constitution
in the capitol building that didn't
happen oh
but during the cheeto dust confederacy
something like that might have happened
and those are the people who want his
statue to remain up there
i wonder why